make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
do not be too proud of this
technological terror you've constructed
the ability to destroy a planet is
insignificant
next to the power of the force or of the
year 2020 which has been
absolute garbage so far what's going on
guys this is rob
and i woke up a little bit ago so any of
you guys who are familiar with my
youtube channel know that i have this
pretty deep voice when i first wake up
uh it will change as we go on through
the video the more that i talk
but we are uh we're covering the secret
origin
of death metal right this is technically
super boy prime versus the batman who
laughs
but uh it's really really cool right
it's a really really amazing story so
what we what we really i wouldn't really
even say that we like anything what we
would normally do
in so far is kind of like doing a bit of
a breakdown about super boy prime before
we actually start the story we don't
need to do because it gets covered in
the story and that really makes a lot of
sense given the fact that superboy prime
hasn't shown up in dc comics for quite
some time and there is a little bit of a
refresher that's needed for people who
are getting into the character for the
very first time because a lot of people
know the character by name they're aware
of
superboy prime the power he possesses
he's probably the strongest version of
superman that we've seen in any of the
crisis events minus
you know the the one that adapts to
everybody's powers and like a few
exceptions here and there but in terms
of like the mainline superman who come
from krypton and that kind of a thing
he's usually considered to be the most
powerful
uh they don't really know the history of
the character and so because of that uh
we get a little bit of an explanation
here
one of the things that does get left out
is the nature of krypton in the sense
that
this this basically takes place in earth
prime and earth prime is
essentially dc stand-in for the real
world right so like our world where
you're watching this video and all that
kind of good stuff uh but the whole idea
behind this
is that that this guy clark kent had
basically come from krypton here in the
real world the difference
is that unlike dc comics in almost any
other universe where krypton
explodes in his universe krypton's
destroyed by the sun
and the result of that is that there is
no kryptonite from the earth prime
universe right kryptonite comes from a
planet krypton
shards that were either found in space
or landed on earth and that's how
superman gets his weakness to green
kryptonite uh the reality is that here
there is no kryptonite anywhere in the
universe and so the result is that
superboy prime does not have a weakness
to kryptonite because it doesn't exist
presumably if it did
he would but the other counterpart to
this or the other components of this is
that kryptonite from other dimensions
other universes does not work on
superboy prime so he has
no inherent immunity to kryptonite in
any form or fashion
it's one of the things that really
bolsters his power now in this moment
he's kind of in a local comic book store
just kind of reading comics and then
some guys show up on him and start
giving him a hard time making fun of him
because he likes superman what kind of
an idiot makes fun of somebody because
they like superman
at this point like these guys right this
kid braverman basically ends up ripping
up the comic book that clark kent's
reading
and then in turn are they just gonna
start beating the crap out of them right
i don't know why you beat somebody up
for liking comics but you know this was
the 1980s things were a little bit
different back then but then laurie
comes out of nowhere basically splashes
water on him and is like my mom owns a
drugstore
you guys are banned for life now lori
was the love interest when when super
boy prime originally showed up in dc
comics back in the day
lori was his love interest and by all
standards of measurement she was
essentially his low his lowest lane
right she was the the counterpart to him
right the the character that would go on
they'd have kids and have a life
together and all that kind of stuff the
caveat to this and
the big kicker of all this is that when
superboy crash landed on earth was
ultimately adopted
by john and naomi kent again he never
really knew anything about about his
origin and so the funny thing is it's
not like his powers came about by way of
him just arbitrarily lifting up a
tractor one day or something like that
his powers had to be activated
and the way this activation came out was
that because of his love for superman
uh lori got him a superman outfit to
wear to this big costume party they were
gonna go to and so once they get to this
beach where all their friends are
dressed up as you know superheroes and
so on and so forth and they're all just
kind of hanging out that a comet passes
by and when this comet passes by it
emits a kind of radiation
that basically activates superboy
prime's powers and now he has all the
powers of superman right he's flying all
that kind of good stuff and he kind of
reminisces
about this right he reminisces about his
life with lori when his powers activated
how like how much he cared about her how
much they were going to go forward
probably have a life together and then
suddenly superman from the main dc
universe popped up and said there's an
event going on called crisis on defended
earth we need your help and ultimately
this led to super boy prime basically
you know joining uh the various
superheroes facing off against the ante
monitor and in the aftermath of that
super boy prime was locked away in a
paradise dimension or went to a paradise
dimension because of the fact that his
home world had been destroyed that earth
prime was basically gone
laurie was gone and the the desire to
get her back the desire for all those
things basically came to fruition with
him
leading to his current state now if you
want to know more about superboy prime
because we don't really have enough time
to cover it all
i'll have the link to infinite crisis
down in the description where you can
basically get caught up with
all the stuff that takes place in
between superboy prime going into the
paradise dimension
at the end of crisis on infinite earth
and the start of this story more or less
right there's a few other things here
and there where they're not super
important uh but
you know infinite crisis is the story
that everybody references when they talk
about super boy pride right
that's like the must-read superboy prime
story and so because of that all the
other heroes who were here after
experiencing their battles with super
boy prime and knowing him as they know
him
a lot of it kind of turns into can we
even really trust this guy
and while he's using his super hearing
to kind of listen to what they're saying
at the end of the day they're just kind
of like
he's kind of like all right these guys
still don't really like me and still
don't really trust me and for good
reason
i mean this guy broke out of the
paradise dimension he literally
shattered the dimensional barrier
broke out of the paradise dimension and
just went on a war path in the main dc
universe there's one point where he
fought the doom patrol the teen titans
young justice and i think justice league
all the same time and like overpowered
all of them
right like he beat them all and was like
killing people and all kinds of stuff he
just become this really twisted and dark
character which was an amazing story the
way it was done it was it was so well
written by jeff johns but what you end
up getting here is in this moment when
he's kind of accepting and coming to
grips with the fact that nobody really
trusts him none of the superheroes on
earth that in reality while reading
about them through comic books in his
own universe uh that he came to
to respect and to adore that you know in
his loss of respect for him for
all these different guys when he was in
the paradise dimension and the events
that followed after they don't see him
as a superhero and so he effectively
became the villain right he became the
one thing he never wanted to be when he
was going through and reading comic
books as a kid
and then suddenly he's met by the
arrival of crypto and crypto is
see this is the thing about crypto
crypto is amazing right the great thing
about dodge if you guys don't own dogs
the great things about dogs is that it
really is just
unconditional love dogs don't care about
about like your your political beliefs
they don't care
they don't care about anything right all
dogs care about is that you love them
and you pet them
and that you feed them and let you take
them for walks and let them go have fun
that's all they care about and they will
love you unconditionally in return and
that kind of unconditional love from
crypto being
basically shown to superboy prime is
something that he hasn't experienced
for a long long long time and it kind of
allows a little bit of a softer side to
it right where he starts talking about
crypto you know and it's like man i'm
when i when i first read a story about
you well as he's petting crypto
suddenly superboy comes running up right
he comes showing up on him counter can't
stupid self he comes showing up on him
and it's just kind of like leave crypto
alone right you know like like you know
if you if you hurt him i'll bash your
brains in right like i'll destroy you
now here's the reason why this is dumb
the last time these two guys fought
conor kent got crushed
and not even by a little bit either it
wasn't even like a close fight
you know where it's like man counter
ken's holding on by a thread guys do you
think he'll pull it out i don't know
super boy prime doesn't look like he has
much
much left either no no no super boy
prime had a full tank and was still
hammering on
conor kent right i mean this guy never
he never had a chance anybody who ever
said that conor can had a chance against
suit boy prime is lying to themselves
that's just the way that is right
superwoman prime was just
that powerful and so the reality of this
is that the reason why they're all kind
of here in this moment
it's because they're waiting on these 52
worlds to arrive that are all basically
filled with different analogues of
superman like we saw this at the end of
i think
death metal number four or death metal
number five but they're all basically
just waiting on all these different
these different heroes or i guess you
know twisted versions of themselves to
show up so they can face off against
them destroy them and then you know
that's basically it
and so what you end up having here this
is a cool moment what you end up having
here
is that in this moment when superboy
prime faces off against this one dark
analog
of superman that as he defeats him and
then ultimately kills him
that he sees his world and then feels it
change and then his thought becomes
okay so like why like why is this the
case right if i if i kill this guy right
like if i if i kill this guy and take
him out
then why does this world change
initially the superheroes think he's
abandoning them but he takes off into
space with this kind of realization and
he says just outside earth's orbit i see
the last 52 worlds
all lined up right the world that this
bad guy created to destroy
everything and everyone the bad guy of
course referencing the batman who laughs
and he says and then i wonder
can i use these can i change all of them
if i kill this monster now
remember the the nature of the dark
multiverse and
presumably the worlds of the batman who
laugh created is that they're dark and
twisted versions of essentially
existing worlds or concepts remember
when it comes to the multiverse and dc
comics there's only really 52 worlds
that are ever established by dc but
there's an actual infinite number of
worlds out there right we just only ever
really see 52 of them and so because of
this
what we're kind of getting here is this
idea that all the batman who laughs
basically did
is take the idea of worlds that
succeeded and then create
in turn like dark multiverse versions of
those right where the worlds have
twisted up and the worlds have been
screwed up the idea seems to be that
there's an anchor point there right
there's a genesis
a point by which that world changed and
if you basically destroy that then what
it's basically doing is
pulling out the wrong jenga piece at the
bottom of a jenga set at the wrong time
and the
entire thing comes crashing down it
creates a cascading effect and so if
that superman in that alternate reality
is dead
then the world will shift back to normal
right presumably the batman who lasts
control over that world will be removed
and it'll it'll go back to the way that
it was supposed to be now
we're not told if it's like an automatic
thing right if like you know this new
new superman is introduced and then like
there's some magic that's done and the
world is twisted up and then like as
soon as as soon as the superman's killed
like the world just snaps back to normal
and everybody's like wow what happened
you know this is kind of crazy we're not
told if it's that way or if it's because
of the death of that dark character
that the world can actually begin the
process of becoming a better place we're
not really told if it's hard and fast or
a little more
you know nuanced in terms of how it
works we're simply just told that
batman who laughs if he's destroyed
these worlds will seemingly continue to
exist but they'll basically function
in a pretty normalized way now one thing
that i do also want to draw your
attention to here is that we were
basically told at the end of the last
issue with death metal that there's only
going to be one continuity after all
this it's seemingly going to be a crisis
event with like a new earth right one
single universe there's not gonna be a
whole bunch of different alternate
realities out there whether that's true
or not
i don't know but if that's true then
seemingly these worlds would have to be
destroyed or removed
somewhere along the line it may just be
one of these things where it's kind of
like a blend between the multiverse
and the the new earth concept after
crisis on infinite earth where basically
there's a multiverse out there we just
never explored we just never see it
right we only ever focus on this one
particular world and that's basically it
it could be
more metaphorical that statement anyway
or it could be literal right where every
single world of the multiverse is
destroyed and there's only one universe
left we don't really know
what we do know is that we end up seeing
superboy prime going directly after the
batman who laughs
and one of the things one of the
comments we get right off the bat here
is that the batman who laughs kind of
analyzes him and says okay
there's more to you than i thought there
would be you're kind of a funny one here
right this is a little bit different
you're kind of a funny one here this is
a little strange
and so the two of them actually end up
fighting against each other now
something that happens here and
something that i'm not really entirely
sure about how i feel
is that superboy prime is able to
successfully go toe-to-toe with the
batman who laughs
something to understand the batman who
laughs is a version of batman
powered by basically dr manhattan's
powers what this really tells us here is
that superboy prime
is equal to dr manhattan in power if not
more powerful and the reason why is
because
as they fight against each other as they
go to go toe-to-toe in this kind of
bare knuckle just knocked down drag out
brawl that there is some some taunting
there is some intimidation going back
and forth and so far superboy prime
talking trash the batman who laughs
talking trash to superboy prime and
superwoman prime is literally getting
the upper hand and absolutely pummeling
this guy
and the batman who laughs does what he
can right and basically says like i can
give you the world that you want
the world where lori's back where
everything you could possibly want would
come true but super boy prime rejects it
because at the end of the day the big
difference between superboy prime and
the batman who laughs
is that prime wanted to do the right
thing right he wanted to get the heroes
back to being traditional good guys it
just happened to be he went about it in
all the wrong ways the batman who laughs
just wants to make everything evil right
he doesn't have any good intentions that
he's implementing in the wrong way the
way superboy prime did
he just wants to he just wants to cause
chaos death instruction and just make
everything really crappy right and so
because of that where you end up having
super boy prime just pummeling the
batman who laughs
then suddenly out of nowhere when he
goes in for the killing blow crypto
shows up
and chris and he's kind of he kind of
tells crypto like go right you can't
stay here
and so that's when things get kind of
bonkers is because the batman who laughs
makes this comment to superboy prime you
can't destroy me any more than i can
destroy you
so let me help you and again that's
where he basically offers him this
opportunity again
and and really like even even batman who
laughs shows him what this world could
look like
right that he could see this world where
he is a member of the justice league he
fights alongside the other superheroes
he's celebrated and accepted as a hero
the world sees him as everything that he
always wanted to be when he was reading
the stories about becoming superman but
at the end of the day
he closes his hand and he says no i
can't accept that right because it's a
world without his parents
it's a world without lori it's a world
without everything he ever wanted and
that's all he ever did want
that's that's that's the important thing
to understand about superboy prime when
you when you reduce him down
past all the infinite crisis past
pummeling the earth's superheroes being
stuck in the source wall
being locked away by the green lanterns
and science cells when you remove
all that stuff right all that talk and
all that jargon and you reduce him down
to his most
base instinct the entire motivation for
everything
superboy prime has ever done in the
history of dc comics
is to get back to his home with his
parents and laurie and that is what made
superboy prime
such an incredible and relatable
character that's what made him so
awesome
is because who of us has not been thrust
in a situation
where we seemingly lose everything we
care about right sometimes you don't
realize what you've lost until it's gone
sometimes you realize what you're giving
up as you do it but regardless of the
situation
you me everybody in this world is
struggling with something and in some
way over the course of our life we've
had to give
something up we didn't want to but we
had to and superboy prime represents
that primal desire in all of us
to go back to the way things were right
to go back to that point in our life
when things were at its high point when
we seemingly had everything we could
possibly want that's a strong urge
that's a strong
feeling and in his desire to get back
there superboy prime
acted on that and seemingly got lost in
his own cause right he ended up becoming
everything that he hated right the one
thing he never wanted to be that's the
thing that he became
what he sees here this is seemingly the
perfect life
without the one thing that he wants the
most right the one thing he wants the
most his parents and lori and as long as
he doesn't have those it's not a world
worth living in and so because of that
he literally balls up and says okay
one last time right one last time and he
basically lets
all of his dreams go right his dreams of
being with lori his dreams of being back
with his mom and his dad right
everything he's been holding on to over
the course of his life he lets all of it
go now here's the reality of this
he never would have been able to pull
this off had he not done that
right had he not let himself go in that
way the reality is sometimes
you just have to let things go right and
just move on as tough as it may be
and as hard as it may be sometimes
that's just what you have to do and
that's what he does right he takes
everything he ever wanted all the life
he wanted to go back to
he balls it up and he just lets it go
and just bam
punches into the batman who laughs and
shatters him now by all
standards of definition all standards of
measurement superboy prime
has seemingly destroyed the batman who
laughs and it's kind of weird
it's a little strange to believe the
death of the batman who laughs
doesn't happen in the main story it
happens in italian it's a little strange
to believe that if i'm being honest
i don't really think it's true and
here's the reason why what you end up
getting here is super boy prime who
basically just kind of crash lands right
that all these worlds are you know
everything's more or less destroyed
right that everything seems to kind of
crack these worlds look like they're
breaking apart uh they literally look
like
they're starting to kind of shake and
just explode they're basically coming to
an
end and when that happens super boy
prime comes crashing down onto the earth
but no one knows that he gets there
right no one knows that he arrives there
they don't even know that he was there
facing off against the batman who laughs
they don't know about that crypto
responds to superboy prime and then
basically howls in the face of the fact
that super boy prime is dead and then
suddenly
he wakes up in his room he just wakes up
in his room reading a comic about his
own death right he's reading this secret
origin comic i know it's a little meta
but that's what used to happen back in
the day like back in the day with earth
prime they were basically reading comics
here in the real world so what you can
do in order to make this easier on
yourself
assume that that we're reading a story
about a kid who's like five blocks away
that's what that's the easiest way to
make this make sense you know to kind of
make it a little more tangible uh but
then lori walks in right and for super
boy prime kind of looking around
like he remembers everything up to that
point and then it's like waking up for
him from a dream he just snaps up in
this place and he's like this doesn't
make any sense like
how are you here right and how is like
this dog like how's crypto here like
how's
this white dog here how is any of this
stuff here this doesn't make any sense
to me right
it shouldn't be this way like this is a
little strange and his initial thought
is that it's somehow a dream or that
none of it's true
and like as he's walking with laurie he
starts talking to her like do you
remember that time we were on the beach
and like the comet passed by and then i
got my powers and i flew up into the sky
and she's like yeah i mean that's a
great story it's a you know it's a cool
story that you love telling but like you
know you're clark him without powers and
that's okay right you're not superman
right and so what ends up happening is
as this car is driving down the road
this kid goes running out into the
street to chase a bouncing ball which is
a pretty
typical situation right kids just run
into the streets chasing balls and so
superboy prime or at least clark goes
running out there to to
save this kid and ends up picking up the
car right now
if i'm being honest with you guys i
think this is all an illusion
i think it's all fake i think that it's
basically the batman who laughs who has
this much power
power enough to create worlds i have a
hard time believing he'd be toppled that
quickly
by super boy prime i think that what
he's done is he's tricked super boy
prime into believing that he's dead and
then in turn he's basically just kind of
conjured this world out of nowhere and
then said like this is the world you
could have
if you leave me be right that's
basically it either that or he's just
gonna torment him again who knows but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob court if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you